that i i definitely believe men and
women are not equal right i've always
believed that there's certain things
that women can't get away with in a
certain things that men can't get away
with it but why do we always antagonize
the things that women can get away with
and not the things that men can example
being
because we said this before
women want a man with sexual experience
and you don't want a woman with sexual
if you're if you're having a fellatio
i'll explain sorry hold on hold on
because you asked so i said
women want men with sexual experience so
if you got if you got with a guy yeah
yeah and he had no sexual experience you
wouldn't be attracted to him why
because he doesn't because he doesn't
know what he's doing in the bedroom
because because there's
okay so you've got attraction before
then it's time to have sex and he
doesn't know what the hell he's doing
okay right
is are you going to continue that
relationship if he's teachable yes so
hang on majority of women don't want to
teach men
there's biological reasons for the
reasons we feel the way we feel if a guy
can get other girls it's a form of
pre-selection
so so that signals to us he could take
care of those women therefore he can
take care of me too so that's that's why
it's attractive to us a man that's been
with more women on the other hand men
value purity because their biological
imperative was they don't want to put
resources into a kid that's not theirs
and so that's why they value a lower
body count because if they don't want to
they don't they want to make sure that
kid is theirs and then if you want to
talk about body count so a woman that's
only had that's a virgin when she gets
married she has an 80 chance of a happy
marriage within 10 years
if she's if she's if she's okay again
we're talking about straps the stats so
this 80 chance of a of a happy marriage
in 10 years if you slept with more than
five people which i think most men pray
for nowadays
they're
their chance of a happy marriage is 25
so it goes from 80 to 25
so and and it keeps dropping lower and
lower go ahead can i ask you a question
so if you got with a woman who didn't
have any sexual experience
would you
um
you teach her
okay and if she wasn't really getting
the hang of it
a man
is um
more willing to be a teacher of a woman
sexually mm-hmm then a woman is to be
i'm not saying that you're not i'm just
saying but if she wasn't getting the
hang of it what would you do well she'd
get it
no you can't say she'd get it
no you can't you can't say no because i
know what kind of time in this scenario
in this scenario i'm giving you
she's not getting it so what would you
do well then i'd leave
after you got married so after marriage
yeah i'm not having i'm not having i
haven't married you and not had sex with
you oh okay also you would have sex with
marriage oh 100 so if she wasn't good in
bed you wouldn't marry her
no like like you were saying if she was
constantly
if she was constantly being taught and
she didn't know what she was doing then
the relationship so she so ultimately
she wasn't good in bed yeah you wouldn't
marry her
uh i'd probably seek elsewhere yeah so
you wouldn't marry her
why is it why is it such a is it
there's a lower bar for a girl to be
good in bed than there is
a man
a man can have sex with a hole in the
wall not know who's on the other side
okay and be absolutely satisfied with
what you just got okay then why wouldn't
you why wouldn't you marry her then
because you can have sex with a hole in
the wall all you need is a hole right
if i can finish women want to feel a lot
of time when i have sex
emotionally connected to the person that
they're having sex with
and man doesn't necessarily have to be
emotionally connected so why would you
leave because because of marriage
i need more than i need more from her
it's not in a marriage than just sex so
why would you leave if it's not just
about jokes about that why would you
leave because because sex is such is a
very big thing for a man but there's
more but there's more to it in a
marriage and you can [ __ ] anything
because that's got a hole thank you
that's what i'm saying contradictory
hang on if i can't hang away if i if i
choose a woman if i choose her and i
like her qualities and she can't have
sex right then if if i would weigh up
hmm
she's got good qualities
might marry her
might cheat on her
okay i'm just gonna be real with you but
if she's got the qualities that she that
is more than just sex i will choose her
okay but if she can't if if if if she's
if she can give good sex and she's got
no wife qualities she's not getting wife
so you'd marry you might marry her but
you'd cheat on her yeah probably if she
doesn't know what is that wouldn't you
say it's kind of a reflection of the
girl if you're bad at sex because it's
like yeah but you want your routine you
don't want to teach her a bad infection
no no i'm saying like it's a it's a like
she's not trying if you like if he knows
if he knows it no if he knows exactly
what he wants and he says this is what
you have to do
women can say to a man this is what i
want in a in a relationship and you
don't get it well the problem is women
don't know what they want
you're making a very very broad
statement because women change their
minds all the time women are known for
changing their mind can i can i just go
back the sex thing
so
you
believe that women want men with
experience yeah we want men with sexual
experience yeah we want men with
experience right
your experience doesn't mean you know
how to please me
just because you've pleased every woman
in this room doesn't mean you know how
to please my body yeah but he's shown
you what you know how to do is have sex
yes but he but he's shown you that he he
can have sex how are you showing me
because you told me what your butt
account is yeah he's showing you that i
like you you carry you can you can you
can you can you know okay you can you
can you could you could tell okay this
is sexual experience
you can
then you can say that but if it's about
sex then it's definitely not going to be
talking about the sexual marketplace
yeah even if it's not the monetary thing
guys one more time i think i'm
delusional because i i think you guys
need to maybe educate me right because
from my delusional brain what i believe
is just because you've had sex with 50
girls doesn't mean you know how to
please me you learn how to please me
from the frequency of how much we have
sex because i always believe the first
time you have sex with someone
maybe if you're in lust with each other
you feel like it's heightened you enjoy
it but as the sex goes on i feel like it
improves because you get to understand
each other and you know each other's
body right so just because you've slept
with 10 girls or 50 girls or whatever i
don't think you know how to please me
you have to understand why didn't you
taylor make your sexual relationship
with him then it's but no i'm just
basing it on what you just said so i'm
saying you can't say your experience
with sex you're good at sex just because
you had sick okay
okay baby
we're saying we're saying that by and
large men that have sex more tend to be
better at sex okay so i'm not i'm not
saying
i'm not i'm not saying that every single
guy that slept with 100 girls knows how
to screw them right some guys don't care
they don't want to do that but by and
large like if you do something more you
get better at it if i play football
every sunday am i more likely to be a
better goal scorer than someone who
doesn't play that's different
it doesn't mean that i'm going to be
ronaldo okay right but i'm saying
if you have experience doing something
that's what attracts you to the person
you know that person has had sexual
experience would you want a virgin man
so can i would you want a virgin you
would want a virgin woman
yes
can i just say there are a lot of people
would you want a virgin man i didn't
know if they're
seriously would you want a virgin man if
he's got a fairy yeah would you hang on
not you do you want a virgin man no
right so you won a mammy's sexual
experience yeah but not that much sexual
experience can i just say
that
what i'm saying is
in terms of just because you've had a
lot of sex does not make you good at sex
a lot of people that have had a lot of
sex that think they are good at sex but
if you ask the person they last had sex
with they'll be like nah i didn't enjoy
the sex that is not your argument the
argument is that women want a man with
sexual experience no one has no one has
disagreed with that though who agree who
did it
no my statement was sorry darling my
statement was why do you think because
you've had sex with more people you can
please me that's what my statement was
it wasn't about women
but the point i was making is women as
women as you've said today women want a
man with sex rich you don't want a
virgin man right you don't want a virgin
but you want to know a man
can at least know
something in the bedroom you don't want
a virgin man so my point is the reason
why it's different for men and women
sleeping around is because men want a
woman who is who has less sexual
experience
women want a man
with sexual experience
does that make sense but they both have
sexual experience
what do you mean you said that the woman
has less but the more less but they both
have sexual experience less or zero
can i just ask a question so who are the
men sleeping with
what do you mean uh women with more
i'm just trying to i'm just trying to
understand is they're not women that
they sleep with so they're sleeping with
women with more sexual experience but
you've got to understand they're
sleeping with women with more sexual
experience on the basis that they have
no intention to wife them okay
so we were saying earlier on a lot of a
lot of women can have sex with men yeah
and think that because they're having
sex with men that they're of that
caliber i agree i'm saying yeah yeah so
men don't just because you can have sex
with a footballer doesn't mean
100 well 100 of women want 20 of men and
some some some surveys say five percent
ten percent fifteen percent so you have
a hundred percent of the women sleeping
with a smaller percentage
and yeah so if you all want so like i
said that goes back to you want a
mommy's sexual experience because if
women are looking for that twenty
percent of men
we already know that 20 of men have got
sexual experience because they've got
women throwing themselves at them on a
constant basis so have you agreed that
just because you had sex with 50 people
doesn't mean you can please me
yeah you agree with that right yes
do you have a need to be right right now
is that what it is
guys that have sex more tend to be
better at sex
i said it does not mean that every
single guy that's had sex with a lot of
girls it's gonna be some kind of some
some some guys are just trying to get in
and get out but you what but you want
that man you want the man that you know
has had sex experience that's my point
he might not be able to please you but
you want him because you know he's had
sex experience you don't want the virgin
man